the housing market is red hot right now
so what were you thinking maybe three
bedroom four bedrooms
i think that might be a little bit above
my budget oh okay so what were you
thinking
i'd love to keep it under a hundred a
hundred thousand dollars
okay i'll see what i can do oh no i
meant a hundred dollars
wait you're hoping to get into real
estate investment for a hundred dollars
that's ridiculous or is it
[Music]
are you itching to get into the real
estate game but lack the tens of
thousands needed for a basic down
payment or
maybe you hate the idea of dragging
yourself to open houses comparing
different backsplash treatments
well there's a way to own real estate
without investing in individual
properties
buying shares of a real estate
investment trust
or reit for short let us give you a tour
a reit is a company that owns and most
of the time operates
income producing real estate they are a
fairly new fixture in the investment
world
the very first reits were created in the
us in 1960
by congress they were designed as a way
for everyday people to own a piece of a
large
real estate investment portfolio since
then they've exploded in popularity
with publicly available reits in 35
countries
valued at over a trillion dollars and
it's easy to see why
reits are historically one of the best
performing asset classes
between 1990 and 2010 the primary equity
reit index
grew at 9.9 percent per year second only
to mid cap stocks also here in america
reits don't have to pay corporate income
tax as long
as 75 or more of the fund's assets
are invested in real estate which means
that the business
overall has a lot more wiggle room cash
flow wise
but the biggest draw for investors is
the income generation
by law reits must pay at least 90
percent of taxable income to investors
in the form of dividends
and they're nothing to sniff at the
average equity reit
one that buys properties pays a five
percent annual dividend
the average mortgage rate which owns
mortgage-backed securities
pays a 10 dividend compare that to the
average s p 500 stock which pays 1.9
and you can start to understand the curb
appeal while reits are required to pay
90 of taxable income out in dividends
most streets actually pay out more than
of income out shareholders but that's
not as exciting as you might think
a hefty 10 payout isn't as attractive if
your
share value falls by 15 that's why it's
important to look at the
total return you can calculate your
total return
by combining the dividend returns along
with the share price
movement when you think about it these
two levers are very much like owning a
physical investment property
on one hand you are bringing in income
from the rent you charge your tenants
then there's the market value of the
home itself that should hopefully be
going up in value over time
so even if you're not making a ton of
profit through the rent after paying a
mortgage tax as an upkeep
you could be experiencing a return
through the appreciation of the property
or it could work vice versa
and like property reits come in a lot of
different styles
for example retail reits invest in
shopping malls and retail outlets
residential reads contain apartment
complexes and manufactured housing
and office reads have you guessed it
office building complexes
they can also focus on specific
locations maybe you're interested in
manhattan real estate or
india's first reit that just debuted in
march 2019
there are plenty of databases out there
that can help you narrow your search by
focus
region historical returns and more the
final consideration
is whether to go public or private
shares and private reits are offered
exclusively through financial advisors
and brokers
and they can offer enticingly high
dividends or
niche specialties like resorts senior
living centers or
timber farms but make sure you put on a
hard hat when checking them out
private reits can pay extremely high
commissions to the brokers that sell
them
sometimes up to 12 percent of your
investment they aren't required to
disclose conflicts of interest
and it's difficult to find performance
data on private reits as a whole
and they aren't very liquid so getting
your money
back quickly can be difficult and
they're usually for accredited investors
only meaning you have to have a million
dollars to invest
or have made over two hundred thousand
dollars for the last two years
if that doesn't sound like you buying a
publicly traded reit is as
easy as buying a share of stock you can
log into an online brokerage account and
just look up the ticker
and if you can't decide on which reik to
pick there are even etfs that own stock
in different re
companies kind of a sampler platter of
real estate holders
you're saying i can buy hundreds of
different pieces of real estate
online without comparing square footage
or worrying about old fixtures or
getting calls from angry tenants in the
middle of the night yep
but there's something special about
owning your own
property taking care of it living in it
sure but
if you live in a city where property
values are inflated or you don't plan to
stay in one place for very long
reits could be a way to dip your toe in
the real estate market for as little as
a hundred bucks
and that's our two cents think you know
what it takes to succeed in the
workplace
how about the new almost entirely online
workplace we're navigating thanks to the
pandemic
thankfully career hacks a new series
here on youtube is here to help you with
the tips and tricks
you didn't know you were missing they
might seem obvious at first but
mastering these tips can make you more
hirable more promotable
happier and garner more respect at work
check it out link in the description and
let them know that two cents
sent you
[Music]
you